let me tell you the rules of my house
number one every conversation is on the
table a hundred percent all the time
there is nothing in our house that we
won't talk about or discuss and so
that's just an ethos right and that can
be about religion that can be about
political topics that can be about
anything
we also don't gossip so we don't talk
crap about other people so my kids know
that it's not a free-for-all and the
rule that my wife and I have is any
question that gets asked whoever gets
asked answers it so there's not a big
there's not a big um production there's
not a big it's like confetti falling
from the sky and the big talk right